um who all do you have on this new album
um
I got a lot of great people Tyler the
Creator who's okay who's the town who's
on the Tyler song Tyler and I just just
wait there's something here just wait
there you may wait long enough for this
interview who's on the Tyler zone drama
it's Tyler and you can't put Tyler on a
song with anybody so it's just Tyler
yeah so he's got track number two or the
intro or what is it it's I mean it feels
like what a way to start track two what
what a way to you know what a way to
come off a Grammy what track number is
it
what a way to start so it's the intro I
love it thank you
um Jack Harlow's on the album I sure
would hope so a little Uzi vert
uh Lil Wayne's on the album Jesus uh 42
dogs on album
um little Russell's on the album lovely
Russell uh sigh hives on the album
carving is on the album
uh moneybagg Yo's on the album Gucci's
on the album Jeezy's on the album nipsy
hustles on the album Nipsey
blast is on the album
did you put Nipsey and blast on a song
together
um I got spit on there
I got some telling me you got nipsy and
blast on the album together I got some
I'm pretty excited for you to hear it
how do you get the nipsy verse
um you know Nipsey did a lot of
recording at uh Mean Street yeah
yeah
so you so you okay lost the archives so
we got this old nipsy verse you reach
out to Black Sam make sure obviously you
have to clear with the family of course
yeah and then and then a lot of that
process and then you send the verse to
blast and say I need a hook
yeah
yeah you know how it goes you know how
to put songs together last and Nipsey
man man whoa featuring another artist
from LA
no no no
wow yeah I can't wait it sounds like a
symbol on the album Simba is Simba in
the wrestling song together no no I love
it shout out to the Bay man yeah whiz is
on there tip is on there so I I feel
like I have some of the
um
you know the the uh
the people you would expect to see work
with drama as well as a lot of like new
voices as well so it's a good you know
combination yo how do you kind of look
back at the Grand Hustle era of your
career because when you were on Grand
Hustle it was like the hottest moving
yeah like I think a lot of things
probably you know kind of went wrong or
you know I mean obviously Bob is a star
I think Trader truth is on Grand Hustle
am I driven tip had a hell of a roster
if we really want to put it into
perspective young bro I actually really
like the guy that snitched Alpha Mega
yeah you like dopamega he was the
hardest but but you know he was kind of
like the first six nine
he was an early teller because he was a
fire he was on that road bro he was on
that record with Busta Rhymes yeah we
had to perform that without tip at the
hip-hop Awards when tip got was that
called hurt yeah it hurt oh that was all
his voice was crazy yeah we performed
that I just somebody just recently sent
me that YouTube video it was like why
clef opened up and then we and then me
Alpha Mega and Buster performed hurt
without tip because he was incarcerated
people were he had just got locked up
like literally that day do you think him
getting locked up like kind of affected
like the trajectory have the label as a
whole in a sense I mean you know because
he had Meek Mill was originally ground
hustle and I didn't know that yeah Meek
was over groundhog I think I did not for
a period of time you know I mean you
know Travis Scott was I remember Travis
Travis was Grand Hustle yeah
um B.o.B Iggy Azalea
um oh man you know tip tip has had a his
hand in the in in a nice you know uh
I don't think he gets the credit that he
should deserve when it comes to like
having a knife for for talent I agree TI
has an amazing eye for talent yeah yeah
and then you know there's others that he
like he talks about you know Savage and
Thug coming to him wanting to sign and
you know him telling him look like I
think you should do it this way I could
give you this million dollars but you
know just I could give you this game
that'll go a lot farther so
um yeah but but as far as like that time
in my career I don't know if what I want
to call it like a golden era but it was
a hell of a it was a hell of a time like
you know being TI's DJ when T.I was like
the hottest number one rapper like he
was literally the hottest rapper out
like you know we was we was doing
tours across the state I went around we
went around the world together
um he was doing [__] Chevy
commercials he was like I was in ATL
like you know he he had the number one
album and number one movie out at the
same time like you know it was on fire I
mean literally I got to go on tour with
Jay-Z because the tip
um and then you know my brand gangster
girls was the hottest thing going so
like you know to be DJ Drama and and
what ti was and for us to you know be
together at that time it was like it was
kind of what I had always
I dreamed for in a way of like DJ artist
relationship like growing up looking at
you know Run DMC and Jam Master Jay and
fresh prince and Jazzy Jeff or being
Rakim or even like cool kid at 50 or
like yeah you guys were like synonymous
with each other for a minute yeah like
green and M early on like when when I
when I when tip was like rising and like
I was doing my thing and I was like oh
yeah like this is this could be my guy
you know what I'm saying so you know I
like I used to literally go to the
studio to the groundhog Studios which
later became my Studios but I would
literally go there like every day just
to be around just to kind of like Vibe
for that DJ Gig because I knew what
that's coming what that could be yeah